Like any other area in the United States,
the state of Florida has a healthy share of
urban legends and local myths.
Take for example the legendary Swamp Ape,
the region’s bigfoot equivalent, a hulking
creature said to run amok in the state’s
many swamps and aquatic areas, identified
by its strong, repugnant odor and deep, guttural
throat-calls.
Or the ghosts of the St. Augustine lighthouse,
a grizzly tale revolving around two young
girls who drowned in the nearby sea while
their mother was working the lighthouse, too
distracted to hear the cries of her children
as they were swallowed by the current and
returned to the brine.
It’s rumored that on some nights, the twins'
laughter and cries are heard from the top
of the lighthouse.
Not scary enough?
What about the devil’s chair?
A seemingly ordinary bench located in the
town of Cassadaga that was supposedly built
by the devil himself.
Every night, at midnight, the man in red returns
to his bench, and if you sit beside him, he’ll
whisper wicked, horrible things into your
ear, leaving you forever scarred and haunted
by the experience.
Just don’t leave a drink behind when you
run off the bench in terror though, another
legend says that any unopened bottles left
on the bench will mysteriously be opened and
drained by the morning.
Torturing damned souls for eternity makes
you a thirsty guy, we guess.
But to a seasoned viewer of SCP Explained,
urban legends and local oddities might seem
a bit mundane in comparison to the strange,
inexplicable anomalies that the SCP Foundation
regularly researches and contains.
After all, the truth is almost always stranger
than fiction, and if an actual anomaly gets
picked up as an urban legend, the SCP Foundation
is going to do everything in their power to
shut it down, cover it up, and make the story
a little more digestible for the general public.
That means relying on the same, tired tropes
and cliches we’ve all heard before.
Cursed dolls, bigfoot-like creatures, ghost
hitchhikers, we all know them, and as fun
as they are, the most popular stories aren’t
always the most unique or interesting.
And if you peer deeper underneath the surface,
you can always find kernels of truth in the
most commonplace of legends.
For example, what’s commonly referred to
as bigfoot, or sasquatch, is actually SCP-1000,
a super-intelligent, prehistoric race of ape
creatures known as the Children of the Night,
who were slaughtered by early humans and forced
to hide from the world in order to preserve
their species.
A cursed object or location?
The Foundation deals with those all of the
time, and stories of ghosts are as commonplace
in the anomalous world as they are in the
ordinary one.
But what about an anomaly that utilizes urban
legends to further its own nefarious goals?
One that’s lifeblood is localized to a single
area?
Today on SCP Explained, we’re going to be
talking about SCP-3640, an anomaly that capitalizes
on the interest and intrigue those urban legends
generate.
Specifically those in the state of Florida.
We already talked about the variety of weird
and creepy stories the state calls its own,
but what else is Florida known for?
Tourism?
Retirement communities?
Beautiful, summer weather?
Slightly crazy individuals making news headlines
for ridiculous reasons?
How about Disney?
That’s right, the state of Florida is known
for Walt Disney World, the granddaddy of all
theme parks that brings in millions of tourist
dollars annually, and the hub for some of
the most iconic characters and stories in
the world.
If you’ve ever been to Disney World, then
you know about the costumed characters that
roam the park.
Silent, mascot costume renditions of your
favorite TV and movie characters, posing for
pictures and having fun with children.
The park is practically infested with them.
They seem inescapable!
It’s pretty understandable that some people
are unsettled by mascots, they can sometimes
be downright creepy.
With those unmoving expressions, giant heads,
unnatural movements, and the faces of familiar
fictional characters, in the right context,
a mascot can be just as scary as any horror
movie monster or urban legend could ever be.
Here’s a situation for you.
You just landed at a Florida airport, you’re
ready to go to Disney World and enjoy a vacation
after you’ve been worked to exhaustion as
a junior researcher at the SCP Foundation.
You want to get familiar with the state, but
you’re trying to cut down on your phone
usage.
After all, you’re on vacation, why not do
things the old fashioned way and unplug from
the electronics?
You spot a brochure rack in the distance,
perfect!
A paper hub for everything tourist-y in the
area.
Among the hundreds of jet skiing courses,
beach information, and mini golf pamphlets,
one brochure in particular stands out to you.
Maybe it’s your background in the anomalous,
but you just can’t help yourself from picking
up a booklet on Florida’s urban legends.
Knowing what’s behind the curtain, working
for the SCP Foundation, really makes these
types of things more amusing.
You’ve seen how the sausage was made, and
it’s a lot more terrifying than anything
known to the general public.
Heck, you know for a fact that the organization
you work for has more likely than not covered
up most of the actual incidents that inspired
these local legends.
Nonetheless, you pick up the brochure, interested
in the self-guided tour of Florida’s paranormal
hotspots, and you’re impressed to find that
this booklet has it all.
Everything from Skunk Apes to a cursed doll,
it’s all in here.
You chuckle, and tuck the pamphlet underneath
your arm.
But little do you know, you’re about to
experience something more horrifying than
any urban legend could ever be.
You see, if you paid attention to your Foundation
briefings before you left the state for Florida,
you would know that any Foundation personnel
who encounter tourist brochure pamphlets advertising
self-guided paranormal tours in Florida are
to bring said pamphlets to the Foundation’s
attention immediately.
Mobile Task Force Lambda-12, nicknamed “Pest
Control”, is primed on-demand for incidents
related to these brochurces.
Why?
Because they’re a part of a phenomenon categorized
by the SCP Foundation as SCP-3640.
But what is SCP-3640?
Why is something as innocuous and fun as a
paranormal travel brochure an object of high
interest for the SCP Foundation?
Well, you, someone who should have maybe listened
to the regional briefing conferences back
at Site-19 before you left on your vacation,
are about to find out.
After pursuing your booklet and ruminating
over the numerous locations at your disposal,
you decide to visit one after you get settled
into your hotel.
After all, you’re about to experience a
week of family-friend fun at the House of
Mouse, why not partake in a little horror
just to get the blood pumping?
A bit of living life on the edge before the
scariest thing you have to deal with is a
$10 bottle of water and a three hour waiting
line to ride that giant golf ball.
You drive all the way out to the location
the pamphlet specified, a bridge by the name
of Sunshine Skyway, located right outside
of Tampa Bay.
Visiting the bridge at night might also get
you a visit from a mysterious and beautiful
hitchhiker woman, who stands on the side of
the bridge and attempts to flag down cars.
If you happen to take her in, she’ll begin
to weep, growing progressively louder and
louder in her screaming and crying until you
reach the other side of the bridge.
And when the driver turns back to ask her
what’s wrong, the woman will have vanished
without a trace.
Sounds like a fun time, right?
Maybe you can find her.
Heck, maybe she’s single and interested
in an enthusiastic and kind junior researcher
of the SCP Foundation?
You would never contain her, you’d promise,
having to raise your voice over the sounds
of her weeping and crying in the backseat
of your car.
Or, maybe not.
This vacation time outside of the lab is making
you think some strange, strange stuff.
Whatever the case is, you want to see a ghost
girl, so you make your way over to the Sunshine
Skyway at 11 at night, just like the pamphlet
specified.
The bridge is strangely empty, especially
for what’s usually a crowded stretch of
the road.
In fact, now that you realize it, there’s
no one else here.
Just you, your car, the black night sky, and
the sound of your humming engine.
Well, up the road you go, looking for this
supposed ghost hitchhiker.
The Skyway is quite the drive, and the longer
you ride, the less safe you feel.
But you’re fine, right?
It’s a very popular bridge, driven by thousands
of people every day and night.
It just so happens to be completely empty
at an ordinary time of night, and that you
can see the dark outline of a figure in the
distance, standing in the middle of the road.
As you drive closer and closer, you start
to make out the figure a bit more.
A circular head, a tall, wide body, and two
more circles on top of that round, ball head.
Closer, a little closer, and… wait, is that-
There’s absolutely no way that’s who you
think it is.
Is that a Mickey Mouse costume standing in
the middle of the road?
It apparently is, and it seems like it’s
not getting out of the way.
You honk your horn, but the overgrown rat
doesn’t listen, it’s still standing there,
unmoving.
You slow down.
You know what Disney’s legal team is capable
of and you are absolutely not going to go
to jail for running over Mickey Mouse, so
if he’s not moving out of the way, you will
instead.
You try to maneuver around the stationary
mascot, but suddenly, out of nowhere, the
thing leaps fifteen feet into the air and
jumps onto your hood.
You scream as the Mickey mascot scitters across
the roof of your car, clawing and tearing
at the sunroof, trying to get in.
You push your foot on the gas as hard as you
can, with enough force to propel Mickey from
the roof, but it’s not enough.
The mascot hits the ground, but immediately
gets back up and starts running after your
car.
Almost instantaneously, it catches up to your
car again, and uses its strength to pry off
the door on the driver’s side of the car,
exposing you and causing you to lose control
of your vehicle.
You swerve, crashing into the side of the
bridge and banging your head off of the steering
wheel.
You never thought your life would result in
death by Mickey Mouse, but the rapidly approaching
costumed creature seems to be saying otherwise.
The Mickey creature bends down, and uses both
of its gloved hands to grab you from your
car seat with enough force to break the seatbelt
and give you minor whiplash from being flung
into the air so quickly.
This is it, you know it’s over, and you
don’t even know what’s going on or why
this is happening.
You’re just another victim of something
you don’t understand, like the countless
dead you spent your life researching.
Or so you think.
Just when you assume that it’s all over,
a shot rings out from across the bridge, and
you see a salvo of bullets pepper Mickey Mouse’s
back, carefully missing you with impressively
accurate precision.
Mickey drops you, banging your head on the
concrete, and runs towards where the bullets
are coming from.
Several armored, heavily armed soldiers appear
from the side of the bridge and circle the
mouse.
They fire again, but it has little effect
on the mascot.
Once again, he lunges forward, knocking a
soldier off his feet.
The mascot dashes off into the distance, leaping
over the side of the bridge.
Though no splash is heard in the water below,
you don’t see the mascot landing or even
escaping.
It’s like he was never there in the first
place.
But at least it’s gone now, and you have
these unknown soldiers to thank for your,
wait, is that an SCP Foundation logo?
Oh no, they’re Foundation Task Force operatives.
Before you’re able to fully regain your
senses, you can already hear the Task Force
captain telling his underling to prep you
for amnestics and an interview.
The soldier approaches you, and you’re thankfully
able to muster out a few choice words.
Namely, “Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
I’m with you guys!
I’m a junior researcher!”
The captain pauses and laughs to himself.
What are the odds?
After you’re processed and taken to the
nearest facility, where your identity as a
card carrying member of the SCP Foundation
is confirmed, you’re let in on what exactly
it was that you just saw back there.
As it turns out, you had an encounter with
SCP-3640, an anomaly centering around a set
of travel brochures that advertise self-guided
tours of all of Florida’s paranormal hotspots.
If someone reads the brochure and goes to
a location at a set time, just like you did,
they’ll be preyed upon by a mysterious,
predatory entity or set of entities that resemble
costumed mascot characters owned by the Walt
Disney Company.
Mickey, Donald, Goofy, the task force captain
explains that they’re all there, and they’re
all over the state of Florida.
Hundreds of mascots, maybe more.
They’re fast, dangerous, and the Foundation
knows remarkably little about them.
Including how they grow, reproduce, or even
consume their prey.
All of the known hotspots advertised in the
pamphlet are routinely watched by members
of the Pest Control mobile task force, where
operatives are authorized to neutralize SCP-3640
entities with lethal force.
Which is how that Task Force was able to thankfully
show up at the right moment and save your
life.
SCP-3640 only attack those who read the brochures,
and haven’t been seen being hostile or hunting
outside of the areas specified by the pamphlet.
After you recollect yourself and thank them,
the captain hands you a file briefing on SCP-3640,
gives you a stern warning, and tells you to
familiarize yourself with it before you leave
the facility.
What a way to start your vacation, you think.
Just when you thought you were able to escape
the daily horrors of working for the Foundation,
you stumble onto an anomaly yourself.
But you undoubtedly have more questions about
SCP-3640.
After all, anyone would after witnessing as
weird and strange an anomaly as that in the
wild.
You ask the captain why the Foundation hasn’t
captured an SCP-3640 instance, especially
if they’re so common in the Florida area.
He sits down, sighs, and explains that the
Foundation did try, awhile back.
It was a standard D-Class test, held in the
St. Johns River, the location of a supposed
“river monster”.
The D-Class personnel was dropped off at the
river bank and told to follow the instructions
in the pamphlet.
If they spotted a mascot, they were to shoot
at it with a tranquilizer gun.
After dredging through the river for a few
minutes and being distracted by a neat looking
alligator, the D-Class eventually came head
to head with none other than Donald Duck himself,
who emerged from the river and immediately
began moving towards the D-Class.
The D-Class naturally freaked out completely,
and ran away from the scene, but Donald was
simply too fast.
Just when he thought he was safe, the Donald
mascot emerged from the shadows and knocked
the camera and radio off of the D-Class’s
head.
There were sounds of a struggle, but the D-Class
never established contact again.
However, his subdermal tracking transmitters
continued to operate, and before they went
offline completely, they luckily detected
the location of the D-Class’s body.
It was just outside of the EPCOT amusement
park.
Engaged by the captain’s story, you ask
him what happened next.
Surely, the Foundation launched an assault
on EPCOT to figure out what happened to the
D-Class, right?
The captain grunts, and tells you that the
rest is classified.
But you’re not satisfied.
You’re refusing to move until you figure
out what happened to this D-Class.
The captain rolls his eyes, and perhaps feeling
sorry for you, decides to tell you the rest
of the story.
Him and his team were deployed just outside
of the EPCOT theme park, right next to a one
story, concrete hut, where the D-Class’s
location was tracked.
They were equipped with heavy arms, a net
launcher, and a flamethrower, all perfect
weapons for subduing these deadly mascots.
While Lambda-12 was typically used to hunting
anomalous bugs and pests, they figured that
hunting down Donald Duck and Minnie Mouse
was more or less the same thing, when you
squint really hard and pretend that they have
wings.
The task force broke into the hut, revealing
it to be a maintenance shed with a mysterious
trap door in the middle of the floor.
Underneath, a ladder led to a tunnel system,
similar to the ones built underneath the Disney
Parks that the employees use to get around
from park to park.
The team spotted several dressing rooms and
storage rooms, all empty and devoid of any
life.
After some exploration, the team followed
a low rumbling noise to a closed door.
They slowly opened it, revealing an abandoned
boiler room, with a white mascot costume at
the foot of the boiler, curled up around an
unknown object.
An operative approached the costume and poked
it with her rifle, identifying it as an empty
Daisy Duck costume.
The team examined it further, and found a
human arm bone inside the suit.
Disgusting, to be sure, but nothing the task
force hadn’t seen before.
They turned over the suit to examine the object
it was curled around, discovering it to be
a purple, plastic egg, with an embryo inside.
Scattered across the floor were more eggshells.
The squad gathered them, as well as the bones
of the D-Class in the costume, to bring back
to the facility.
Suddenly, the task force heard noises in the
distance, and assumed an attack formation.
They noticed the floor of the entrance they
came in was now covered in dark fluid and
polyester stuffing.
The trail of liquid exactly matched their
path of infiltration into the tunnel.
After determining the situation to be safe,
the squad carefully left the tunnel the way
they came, bringing the costume and the egg
with them.
After several weeks, the egg hatched into
a miniature stuffed donald duck toy.
The Foundation dissected it, discovering it
to contain a plastic endoskeleton and a rudimentary
polyester stuffing muscular system inside.
And that was everything the captain had to
say.
There was never any other leads on the SCP-3640
anomaly, just strangeness and inexplicable
inability to capture or understand the mascots.
You thanked the captain for not only saving
you, but explaining what was going on.
Before you left the facility to go back to
your regular, foundation-less vacation, you
took another glance at the document the Captain
handed to you.
On the back page was a chilling letter, dated
from 1979, written to Florida governor Reuben
Askew by the Walt Disney Company.
It read:
The Walt Disney Company thanks you for your
cooperation in this matter regarding the unlicensed
Walt Disney character operators.
Please pass along the following information,
collected by the outstanding men and women
of the City of Orlando's Police Department,
to the Florida National Guard:
If a character is spotted, call to get its
attention and then rapidly flash your flashlights
at the costume.
If it does not flinch, fire on sight.
Aim at the head if possible; else, aim at
the knees to disable them and then finish
them off with head shots.
Body shots have been shown to lack effectiveness.
Deceased characters are to be incinerated.
No other means of disposal are advised.
We are currently pursuing alternative legal
means of shutting down these unlicensed operators
and hope to achieve a settlement within the
end of the year.
Cordially yours,
The Walt Disney Company
Now go watch “SCP-2805 - Disney on Ice”
and “SCP-823 - Carnival of Horrors” for
more anomalous theme park madness from SCP
Explained!